o
boa noite sou sandri medeiros 36 anos
uma coisa que eu estava me questionando
isto me questionando até há pouco
é o que eu estou fazendo aqui não é
retórica
a filosofia é o que eu estou fazendo
aqui no tek nesse momento agora eu
assisti cada uma das palestras estou
agraciado com a presença de cada um de
vocês na minha vida agora e eu fiquei
pensando o ser humano tem essa
capacidade quando ele não sabe uma
resposta ele a cria com ele descobre eu
criei minha resposta para essa pergunta
eu estou aqui para cumprir com a cota de
pessoas normais
todas as pessoas aqui que eu vi hoje são
espetaculares são magníficas eu sou o
cara normal da história é o lado bom
nisso vocês vão se identificar comigo
pelo menos 99% não estou na minha cidade
mas acredito que 99% das pessoas se
acham normais então acho que vocês vão
se identificar com um cara normal é essa
capacidade de criar uma resposta é
justamente a coisa que eu acho mais
interessante no ser humano
essa capacidade de racionalizar gerar
quiser de organizar e montar uma fala
não é um texto fazer uma pesquisa é a
coisa mais fascinante é o dom mais
interessante que nós temos
eu acredito que seja um dom divino
enquanto algumas pessoas que não têm
religião não podem deixar de crer que é
um dom
pode não ser divino mas é um dom eu tive
uma experiência interessante quando eu
cuidei de uma tia minha nos seus últimos
meses de vida em um tratamento contra o
câncer que ela infelizmente não venceu é
uma pessoa incrível magnífica
inteligente brilhante um raciocínio
rápido sabe aquelas pessoas
interessantes
em determinado momento do tratamento ela
perdeu isso ela não tinha mais qualquer
tipo de reação
ela não falava
raciocinava então aquele momento eu
percebi que minha tia tinha ido a alma
dela foi a morte biológica só foi
constatada dias depois mas o meu ver ela
faleceu naquele momento então pedi a
deus que nunca passa por uma situação
assim porque a coisa mais interessante
que eu posso ter uma inteligência meu
raciocínio ea capacidade transformadora
criativa
eu sofri um acidente chega aos 23 anos
de idade era policial militar pelo
batalhão de operações especiais e numa
ação em rua e foi alvejado com tiro de
calibre 12 que resultou na amputação da
minha perna
a partir daquele momento eu descobri que
eu tinha que ser o dobro de esperteza
que eu era antes
o que eu fiz agora de me locomover daqui
de onde estava sentado pro palco exige
de mim uma racionalização de cada
movimento
quando você pensa de madrugada em ir ao
banheiro você simplesmente se levanta e
vai eu tenho que levantar e pensar que
ao desapoia minha perna direita ea
prótese vai dobrar vai fazer um
movimento que eu tenho que controlar e
quando ele chegará a depositar o pé no
chão é que eu possa apoiá lo de novo se
eu não fizer isso da maneira certa tinha
ela vai dobrar para trás eu vou levar
uma queda como eu levei essa semana de
moto quando eu tentei apoiando a perna
ela estava dobrada
então eu passei a ter que trabalham em
mim característica que até então não
tinha de antecipação o tempo todo eu
dirigi por muito tempo um carro sem
adaptação alguma ea minha maneira de
dirigir justamente me antecipar todo e
qualquer movimento então tinha que
observar muito mais o trânsito tinha que
prevê um momento de parada eu tinha que
desengata marcha porque se não quando eu
fui assim o carro apagar e daquela treme
tinha então eu voltava marcha pregava o
carro depois engatar uma marcha saiu
normalmente essa capacidade uma
capacidade humana e eu não vejo nada
especial por causa disso eu tinha duas
condições na vida quando do meu acidente
uma delas era ficar deitado esperando
cantadores receber por mês um pingadinho
livre e viver minha vida continua a
depressão ou coisa parecida
eu podia continuar optei por continuar
por pura teimosia porque ficou horrível
show dela sérgio ficou horrível nariz
enorme
então nesse contexto entrou
fisiculturismo na minha vida já bem
depois eu fui convidado por um técnico a
participar de um campeonato e aí a gente
fez todo estudo e pra mim o
fisiculturismo era uma coisa idiota eu
achava estranho um cara bombado de sunga
fazendo um monte de pose para um monte
de gente
tanto que o tempo não colocar um slide
aqui porque assim meio estranho ficar
posando de sunga na frente todos vocês
e aí com essa proposta houve uma quebra
de paradigma fisiculturismo é um esporte
extremamente estético você tem que ser
bonito
você tem que estar com o corpo em forma
e conseguir isso o amputado é uma quebra
de paradigma inclusive interna
eu passei grande parte do tempo como
jessica falou negando isso e me
escondendo usando calça jeans o tempo
todo tentando disfarçar minha marcha o
melhor possível para que as pessoas não
notar se sentia muito orgulho quando as
pessoas morrem mas eu nem percebi
naquele momento ela está de sunga e não
é uma ação normal não é sobre o ocorrido
exposto a milhares de pessoas inclusive
depois vídeo ou coisa parecida e eu
descobri que eu era o primeiro
fisiculturista amputado do brasil
isso me foi totalmente estranho mas na
verdade não é essa pegada que eu quero
levar para o meu top é passado
a verdade é que o fisiculturismo e tudo
isso que eu contei são apenas uma
metáfora do que é a minha trajetória
eu acredito que todos nós temos esse
poder incrível transformador e criativo
hoje houve exemplos brilhantes aqui
estou agraciado como falei maravilhado
com tanta gente interessante
ea verdade é que a gente todos aqui têm
esse mesmo potencial e eu acho que a
gente deixa de trabalhar esse potencial
às vezes por comodismo
às vezes por causa do cotidiano que vai
te matando isso você vai deixando as
coisas passar
eu tentei gravar inúmeras falhas para
esse toque de cor achava que ia ser
maneira mais interessante é uma
inclusive das meninas da produção alguns
em uma delas estava dirigindo olha que
beleza dirigindo gravando toque e um
rapaz me fechou e eu sentia aquele ódio
terrível que acho que todo mundo aqui já
sentiu no trânsito pela vontade de bater
no cara
ele me fechou toque no freio e não
batemos o carro de jogo na minha frente
e depois ele jogou pra esquerda foi para
a faixa de desaceleração e seguir o
caminho dele eu percebi naquele momento
que ao tocar no freio
eu fiz com que ele flui com que meu
caminho fluísse que o trânsito continue
cada um de nós continuou sua trajetória
então eu percebi que uma atitude
ignorante minha sogra me tornar mais
ignorante enquanto ao passo que às vezes
pisar no freio na freada esperar a
pessoa passar vai se tornar uma pessoa
maior e melhor é uma questão talvez de
humildade que a gente tanto esquece e
que alguns valores são esquecidos estão
trocados local
às vezes colocam humildade como
submissão quando o meu ver humildade
justamente o que torna maior
eu tenho uma mania essa mania de de
pensar em tudo e tal de movimento de que
eu vou fazer de otimização de
organização
eu geralmente moss eu tomo café da manhã
em uma padaria e aquele horário de pico
as pessoas deixam lhes copos e tal
aquela bagunça terrível e eu não me
contentando em arrumar apenas a minha
mesa pra eu poder tomar café e decide
arrumar as mesas do lado todo dia as
pessoas estão ocupadas
existe um provérbio chinês que diz que
um homem a atravessar o rio deixa de ser
o mesmo homem tanto quanto o rio deixa
de ser o mesmo rio
eu acredito nisso então acredito que a
minha trajetória não é para passar
batido nessa vida
eu acredito que eu tenho esse poder de
elemento transformador e mesmo que o
monte uma grande empresa mesmo que no
monte uma ong
mesmo que não saia daqui pegando todos
os animais que estiverem morando na rua
eu posso causar com pequenos gestos
grandes revoluções
então a minha perspectiva de vida é
muito simples eu acredito que ao
adentrar um ambiente quando eu saí desse
ambiente ele tem que estar melhor do que
quando cheguei
é básico é simples não jogar papel na
rua coisa boba
como estou falando são coisas normais
não estou pedindo propondo nada
excepcional como a gente viu aqui
pessoas transformando papel e terra em
construção
transformando a química física professor
de cálculo que consegue transformar
coisa em algo aceitável e eu não aceito
cálculo não consigo
como é que ele consegue
eu sou professor de humanas história
simples lecionar agora tornar cálculo
interessante é nossa
parabéns resumindo um pouco disso tudo
eu tinha por volta de 12 a 13 anos
quando eu comecei a me envolver com
música e eu não sabia afinal meu violão
havia um senhor morava próximo à minha
casa
alcoólatra ele tinha residência mas ele
basicamente morava na rua já porque ele
bebia ficava caída no chão enfim era uma
figura dessas guias todo mundo tem na
sua infância e eu me aproximei dele
pedir toda vez que ele afinal eu vou
longe e tocavam as músicas e daí surgiu
uma grande amizade
cansei de levar o seu joão saudosos e
joão que já se foi até a casa dele
bêbado ele coloca em casa em segurança
quando aconteceu o acidente ele não pôde
visitar ele tinha um aspecto já bastante
debilitado sujo e fedido enfim não
deixaram entrar no hospital
a gente foi se rever já estava em casa
bastante debilitada ainda andando de
cadeira de rodas não fazia uso de
prótese enfim ele chegou em lágrimas pra
mim e disse uma coisa que eu quero
deixar para vocês
ele virou pra mim e falou meu filho que
não pode correr aprende a voar então eu
acredito que é isso que eu tento fazer a
minha vida todos os dias ao acordar o
meu único inimigo dessa competitividade
ilusória que a gente leva o nosso dia a
dia sou eu de ontem
eu quero ser melhor que ontem e amanhã
você melhor que hoje
eu gostaria que tentássemos isso porque
o melhor pai o melhor filho melhor
vizinho é um elemento multiplicador de
algo bom que a sociedade precisa disso
foi uma honra
muito obrigado